A LOT OF FLUID INFORMATION,
WE'LL KEEP YOU POSTED FROM
AUSTIN TONIGHT.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: AS YOU CAN SEE, WE
ARE TRYING TO SORT OUT THOSE
BASIC FACTS OF THIS AND AS WE
ARE, THE USUAL FORCES OF
DIVISION HAVE TRIED TO TURN THIS
INTO SOME KIND OF IDENTITY
POLITICS FORUM.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IMMEDIATELY
DEMANDED THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
CLASSIFY THESE KILLINGS AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISM, THEY
SUGGESTED THEY WERE RACIAL
MOTIVATIONS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW VERY MUCH AT ALL
AT THIS POINT.
HERE ARE A FEW OF THE UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS STILL OUT THERE.
FIRST OF ALL, WHO IS DOING THIS?
WE HAVE NO NAME, NO FACE, NOT
EVEN A GRAINY PHOTOGRAPH OR
POLICE SKETCH OF A SUSPECT.
THE ATTACKER OR ATTACKERS REMAIN
TOTALLY MYSTERIOUS.
WE'RE NOT EVEN SURE IF IT'S A
SINGLE PERSON, IT COULD BE
SEVERAL, IT COULD BE AN
ORGANIZED EFFORT BY A TERROR
GROUP.
IT COULD POSSIBLY BE ONE BOMB
WAS A COPYCAT.
WHAT'S THE MOTIVE?
NO NOTES HAVE SURFACED, NO
MANIFESTO, TO PLEASE THINK
THERE'S A PATTERN TO THE
ATTACKS?
THE FIRST TWO BOMBS WENT TO
BLACK FAMILIES IN AUSTIN, THE
THIRD BOMB WAS SENT TO A
HISPANIC WOMAN.
POLICE SAY THAT BOMB WAS
ADDRESSED TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
WHO WAS THAT QUESTION WHAT DOES
SHE HAVE ANYTHING IN COMMON WITH
THE FIRST TWO PEOPLE?
WHAT ABOUT THE BOTTOM OF THE
FEDEX FACILITY TODAY?
THE TARGETS TODAY WERE WHITE.
MOTIVES IN THIS CASE TEND TO BE
IMPOSSIBLE TO GUESS WITHOUT
EVIDENCE, THAT DOESN'T STOP
PEOPLE FROM TRYING.
REMEMBER THE UNABOMBER WAS
WAGING A ONE-MAN WAR AGAINST THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING FBI
PROFILERS SURMISED OR DID AND
WHAT DO THE BOMBS THEMSELVES
TELL US?
IS THERE A PATTERN TO THEIR
DESIGN?
DO THEY BEAR ANY RESEMBLANCE TO
IEDs USED IN THE MIDDLE EAST?
LAST AND MORE IMPORTANT, HOW
CLOSE ARE PLEASED TO CATCHING
WHOEVER IS DOING THIS?
THE FEDEX TURNED OVER AN
UNEXPLODED BOMB TO POLICE AND
POLICE BELIEVE THEY KNOW WHERE
THE BOMBS WERE SENT FROM.
WILL THAT LEAD ANYWHERE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
ALL THESE QUESTIONS, NEED TO BE
ANSWERED IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND
THE ATTACKS AND WHETHER THERE
ARE BROADER IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
REST OF US.